patrick henry philippe bertrand
patrick henry le détenu le plus détesté
de france philippe bertrand le petit
garçon pour lequel chacun de nous a le
plus espéré pleurait ce procès de trois
face ouvrir mardi et il doit durer
jusqu'à la fin la semaine c'est un
procès que nous essaierons avec paul
lefèvre de vous commenter avec le
maximum de recul et c'est un procès
douloureux
c'est un procès que les troyens eux
mêmes vont s'efforcer de regarder de
suivre avec le minimum de passion et ce
sera difficile
pourtant là bas où le verrai tout au
long de l'enquêté réalisée par claude
sérillon et simon dre la barbe de la
tristesse l'a emporté sur la colère
derrière ce mur de la prison de chaumont
à l'écart des autres détenus dans une
cellule surveillé jour et nuit depuis le
17 février 1976 patrick henry un homme
jeune à peine 24 ans au physique moyen
accusé d'enlèvement et de séquestration
d'enfants suivis de meurtre il encourt
la peine capitale
le vendredi 30 janvier peu après midi
les enfants de l'école saint pierre une
école du centre de trois sortent en
courant
le petit philippe bertrand sept ans à
quelques dizaines de mètres effectué à
pied pour retrouver son père patrick
henri laborde et l'enlève à ce moment
philippe bertrand le connaissait il
l'avait déjà vue chez ses parents puis
l'enfant est conduit dans cet hôtel des
charmilles et enfermé dans une chambre
au dessus de la salle du café
c'est là que philippe bertrand et tués
le lendemain après midi si l'on en croit
la version de son meurtrier trois
semaines plus tard patrick henry est
arrêté moins d'un an après il est jugé
face au magasin d'assurance du père de
sa victime
je crois beaucoup à la justice populaire
et la justice populaire
elle a toujours été très fidèle à sa
mission par conséquent il n'y a pas de
raison qu à trois il en soit
différemment
même si il ya un état d'esprit même s'il
ya une ambiance défavorable lorsque un
jury gravi les marches qui l'amène à
siéger dans une enceinte de justice mais
il prend tout de suite et il acquiert
tout de suite une api complètement
différente de celle qu'ils pouvaient
avoir précédemment
c'est à cela que je peux je crois à leur
faire confiance
vous ne craignez pas la vengeance il
peut tu avoir un esprit de vengeance
mais vous savez il ya des vengeances qui
s'explique
de toute façon j'espère plus que je ne
le crois mais je lui souhaite ardemment
et je suis même convaincu qu'en
définitive nous et parviendront c'est à
cela que nous essaierons d'aboutir nous
essaierons de dire que en définitive la
franche ans n'a pas sa place dans une
enceinte de justice
ce n'est plus à trois la même à part en
colère on en parle moins mais ce n'est
pas l'oubli beaucoup dans la ville
ajoute qu'aucun juré d'assises n'osera
se prononcer contre la peine capitale
les troyens n'ont pas effacé de leurs
souvenirs ses obsèques du petit philippe
d'autres en sont encore aux drames qui
se déroula dans leur département de
l'aube à la centrale de clairvaux relief
un peu plus de cinq ans et puis
l'habitant de troie peut toujours relire
les journaux ce n'est pas au hasard des
titres de la presse régionale nationale
qu'il y trouvera quelques mesures
quelques mots réfléchi
le ministre et maire de la ville comme
d'autres ministres ne réclame est il pas
déjà un châtiment définitif aujourd'hui
c'est vrai le ton est plus serein le
drame de la mort de philippe bertrand
est encore très présent dans le coeur de
tous les troyens comme d'ailleurs de
tous les français par leur attitude de
réserve je puis vous garantir qu'ils
sont remarquer l'importance qu'ils
attachent à préserver la sérénité de la
justice
néanmoins je crois que par leur silence
ils marqueront leur deuil et le respect
qu'ils doivent
à la souffrance de cette famille
éprouvée
soixante quinze mille habitants dont un
quart de jeunes scolarisés des emplois
féminins dans la bonneterie qui n'est
plus ce qu'elle était une grande
bourgeoisie et une majorité de ruraux
partageant leurs voix politiques
équitablement à droite et à gauche
et puis une image de français moyens
aimant le bon ordre peu disert c'est en
raccourci cette ville bouleversé il ya
moins d'un an par la mort d'un enfant
les troyens ont senti au plus profond
d'eux mêmes la douleur de cette affaire
et ils ont partagé vraiment la peine des
parents le ressenti au profond d'eux
mêmes c'est certain que qui m'a choqué
profondément points seulement en
journalisme donc troyen c'est la
peinture c'est l'image qu'on veut donner
de notre ville à lire certains confrères
parisiens on a l'impression qu'ici c'est
c'est la jungle c'est le far west
c'est profondément ridicule 3 c'est une
ville comme une autre avec sans doute
des excités mais pas plus à 3
qu'ailleurs je ne vois pas en quoi on
puisse faire de notre ville
la peinture d'une ville sanguinaire nous
ne sommes pas des buveurs de sang jugé
la sphère patrick henry l'a3 à perpignan
à strasbourg après ce que je crois que
ça doit être pareil
voilà donc trois vieilles cités de
province industrieuse avec ses maisons
pour cartes postales nous n'y avons pas
trouvé les manifestations de haine
annoncé au certes lorsque patrick henry
comparaîtra il y aura bien des cris dans
la foule anonyme des cris réclamant sa
mort mais le plus inquiétant au fond
pour l'idée de justice que chacun doit
avoir c'est l'impression que déjà le
verdict est rendu que le procès ne sert
plus à rien